let's bring in uh reggie miller the hall
of famer he's out of the bubble back in
l.a but back in orlando on
saturday to call second round playoff
action where do you want to start
what games from last night or yesterday
let me start with the clippers because
uh and i've said this on
this show many times i personally
believe they're the favorite to come out
of the west
and win a championship but something is
concerning me about them
every time i'm on here i say they have
the two best wing defenders in the game
arguably and paul george and kawhi
leonard
and rightfully so at any given night
they can shut you down
and you're gonna have to win four games
for the clippers
their defense isn't where i would like
for it to be
again it's only one playoff game but i
like to
look at patterns and you know even
though it was
you know eight scrimmage games and three
or eight
playing seating games and three
scrimmages um
their defense now again they haven't
been whole last night was the first time
they were whole with montrose harold
actually being
in the lineup um but their defense is
is kind of concerning to me
luca had a big night last night uh
harden had his way with him during the
seating games devon
booker if you remember hit the game
winner over paul george and kwai leonard
their defense isn't where i want it to
be i'm still
picking them and i know they can turn it
on when they want but i just don't think
their defense
is as good as it should be when you look
at
um all the players that are on this team
it could be much better and they could
have easily lost that game if porzingis
doesn't get tossed and he can't allow
himself to get into that situation he
knows what morris's role is
and he fell for that uh i was shocked
that morris wasn't teed up or wasn't
thrown out because he initiated this
he grabs luca and spins him around and
that's when luca like what are you doing
here
and then porzingis came in porzingis
blocks the shot and then he
waves his fist in the air and then i
he shouldn't have been tossed from that
game reg i agree with you 100
i will say this for the league terrible
call
terrible judgment by the three officials
because as you see when he walks in
number one
he's not the as you you mentioned he
didn't initiate
the scuffle between the two and to me
i mean i hearken back to the 90s in the
early 2000s i mean
if that's an offense where you get
thrown out
it's uh that can't happen but on the
flip side
he knew he knew he already had one tech
and you can't put yourself
in that position where the officials are
gonna go to the video
and it was a terrible call in my opinion
play on this is the playoffs you want
your best players on the floor
but i can see where the league the
league is different than it was in the
90s
um but i wondered reg about we've seen
this with baseball they don't want bench
clearing brawls they don't want any
altercations
granted baseball players are together
you know they're they're
they're you know it's i think there's a
tight leash that they're running here
and maybe just the optics of those guys
getting
face to face with one another and maybe
the nba unless they haven't warned the
players
but it felt like they're trying to be
overly cautious with something like that
so i don't know if that played you you
know i'll tell you what theodore if
porzingis has a problem with marcus
morris hey dude i'll meet you at the
pool
after the game since we're staying in
the same hotel
so all this you know pumping out your
chest and being tough
dude i'm gonna see you in two hours uh
in the mess hall
so why do it on the court and jeopardize
you know your team's success or defeat
when you can meet up with a dude
a couple hours later you know by the
pool
luca goes for 42 but has 11 turnovers
and a lot of that is is he really has to
force the action
uh when you when you watch the mavs an
entire game
you i come away with a different
appreciation because
it's like iverson with the sixers you
you have to
create offense every single night and
you see that with luca
11 turnovers you know he called it a
terrible game it wasn't
but he was trying to do the best he
could and you know he's going against
the clippers
uh what did you think of luca's
performance now remember
uh for the mavericks they play five out
they have no low post thread
so they're all surrounded on the
three-point line and it's all predicated
on the dribble penetration of luca so
when
hardaway and curry and porzingis you
know they do a lot of high screen roll
with luca and porzingis
when those guys are knocking down threes
and then luke is able to get all the way
to the hole because you're guarding the
threes
this mavericks team is very difficult to
beat but because they don't have that
low
post threat you're right it puts so much
pressure
on luca to you know be the penetrator
and make sure
everyone else is fed and at times it can
be exhausting
and he's trying to force the issue and i
will say this
the length of the clippers again i wish
they would be a little bit better
defensively
but the length of the clippers because
these guys can play multiple positions
and they've got to be able to make
multiple plays defensively
and i think that's where the turnovers
are coming from luca
is because of the length of the clippers
are able to you know absorb his
penetration
and they're almost basically saying okay
well you can get your 30 or 40
but we're gonna shut everyone else down
and i think we kind of saw that in game
one
better series thunder rockets blazers
lakers oh i want to see both of them the
only thing
reason why i will go with blazer lakers
is because right now the headlining show
is dame dolla and his sidekick cj
mccollum playing you know with an
injured back
is must-see tv now
for the blazers they can score with the
best of them and they've got
two closers in the two guys i mentioned
problem is
you can get whatever you want against
them at the other end
they were very fortunate to even be in
the playoffs because they didn't control
their destiny
charis levert controlled their destiny
and missed that shot
in that last game so if he makes that
we're not even talking about it in my
opinion
they just took advantage of a very young
and inexperienced memphis grizzlies team
um cream rose and those guys have been
deep in the playoffs
they understand what playoff type
basketball
even those were playing games they
understood in the moment the memphis
grizzly and john morant were probably
just happy to be there
and and playing well and had a chance to
win that game and didn't
but now you're going against lebron
james and anthony davis and kyle kuzma
yes they haven't shot the ball
particularly well
but more experience and you're going
against two
top ten two top five players in a.d and
lebron
so yes you got damon and cj and you've
got biggs and nurkic and collins and
you've got
look carmelo has revamped his career but
you can get anything you want
against them and that's the problem why
i'm
you know everyone's saying the blazers
are going to beat the lakers
let's let's hold up on that for a little
bit and also
anthony davis is making his playoff
debut you know he played a lot of
meaningless games
great player meaningless games now they
mean an awful lot
and it might help him that he is not
at staples or not on the road that
from the standpoint of a you know a home
court advantage for somebody else he's
in the bubble
and with the sterile environment i don't
know if that
helps him um or that at least doesn't
hurt him because at staples you know the
crowd is going to get
like they're going to want you to be the
best player on the floor
not lebron a.d has to be the best player
on the floor
i wonder how he processes all this
having not been in this situation before
theodore i'm going to say this anthony
davis has to be the best player in this
series
not lebron not lebron not dame dolla
not cj mccomb anthony davis and even
going forward but particularly in this
series he has to dominate
nurkic and zach collins he cannot let
them off the hook
and so many bunny shots that he missed
in those eight seating games did not
shoot the ball particularly well
wasn't aggressive of none enough to me
18 to 25 field goal attempts
he's got to get to the line 10 times he
should be averaging
30 plus versus the blazers because again
defensively this is not this is not the
clippers he should get whatever he
want and if i'm lebron and he's what 26
27 i've got to use these young legs
get me to the promised land young fella
and he's got to be the best player in
this series
we were wondering this earlier in the
show if i said you could have luca
or christops porzingis or jason tatum
and jaylen brown
wow i would probably go with
jalen brown and tato because
they play both ways uh luca and
uh porzingis are fantastic offensively
and i know porzingis is a is a great
shot blocker
but to me uh tatum and brown
and i think this is a coming out party
for jalen brown i i personally felt he
should have been on the all-star
uh team this year they went with kimba
and tatum
and that's fine they deserved it but
brown
is having a coming out party down in
orlando
and you know he's really become
the almost their second best player
behind tatum because of the
knee injury to kimba yeah and hayward
you know
he got hurt last night with an ankle
injury so
to me jaylen brown is the second best
player on that team
um so i would probably go with those two
guys from boston
but that's no slight to porzingis and uh
doncic
he's reggie miller the hall of famer the
turner sports analyst he'll be back in
the bubble on saturday calling
second round playoff action is there
still the knock on european players
that they're soft that you can be
physical with them because i wondered
with luca feels like the best way to
guard him like putting a body on him
being physical with him even though he's
a grown man at 20 but
that was always the label back when you
played european players were soft
are they still viewed as soft absolutely
not
and uh for those of you for those people
that think that luca is like that
you're talking about he's a grown man
now he was
13 14 15 playing professional basketball
against grown men so you're talking
about a young boy who had to grow up
quickly
so absolutely not he's as tough as they
come
and i think the mold a lot of that was
broken from
dirk and manu uh deadlift shrimp who i
played with
um those guys were so mentally tough
and physically tough as well so i i
think well they made fun of dirk
when he first got here i remember he
said jump shooting
but if you look and evolve throughout
his career
tough as nails play hurt could play
through injury
um no dirk was one of the one one of the
toughest guys
that i ever had to play against the
thunder and rockets i wonder what's at
stake here for the rockets reg
when you know they went all in gave up
those draft picks
they got rid of chris paul you know hard
and paul didn't
you know coexist now you bring in
russell westbrook
what's at stake here in this this
playoff
probably bragging rights you know i told
you so darrell moray for
chris paul but is dan tony's job at
stake here
reg if they don't get to the western
conference finals i get the feeling
could be mike d'antoni i didn't think i
didn't think alvin's injury
would be let go with all the you know
injuries to zion and
yeah what was going on with the pelicans
i really do believe
d'antoni could be dead men walking um if
they don't get to the conference finals
but again
they're starting this series from
everything i'm hearing without russell
westbrook
so you're not you're happy you're not
having your second best player on the
floor
as great as james harden is
and he's been fantastic even in the
restart um
he needs westbrook westbrook to be
effective
in that dribble penetration because when
you're going to play six seven and
shorter which their starting lineup is
you've got to have dribble penetration
and harden can get all the way to the
cup
but what made them so successful is they
had two guys that could do that
and that opened it up for gordon or
covington for rivers those guys knocking
down
shots so to only have one and if you're
the thunder you have plenty of guys that
can cover james harp
not necessarily stop them but try to
wear him down
it's going to be very difficult in my
opinion for them to get out of this
series
depending on when uh russell westbrook
comes back
if you could have john moran or zion
williamson
right now
i know i'm probably going to get killed
for this well it depends am i a
struggling organization i just want to
put people in the seats i'm going to go
with zion
if i'm trying to win right now i'm gonna
go with john morant
because john morant's gonna give me 75
to 82 games during the regular season
i don't know how many games zion is
going to play theodore
he's got to get his body straight and
look i i don't want to kill the pelicans
but to me i think they're just doing him
a disservice
by saying he's okay at that weight where
clearly he is not
as soon as the lockdown happened or the
suspension of play
i would have had a staff member with him
that whole four four and a half months
working on his game
and making sure he ate right he is too
big so you're asking me
if i want to put people in the stands
and you know yeah i'm going to go with
zion because
that's what he's going to do i don't
know how many games he's going to play
john morant is
he's going to be one of the top point
guards in the next three years
maybe even sooner yeah i'm with you on
that i i said john morant because i
there's uncertainty with zion and we
know that he's in a race with his body
because you you can only be so big for
so long
and be able to do what he's doing
whereas john morant's going to get it
bigger
and he's going to fill out and he's
naturally yeah
and uh and so i i said john morant too
but i'm with you if you're putting fans
in the stands you want zion before i let
you go
we talked about unwritten rules in
baseball when you can swing on a 3-0
pitch
like in basketball in the nba
what is the unwritten rule let's say
you're up
15 in the fourth quarter in the final
two minutes are you allowed to take a
three
are you allowed to dunk or celebrate or
anything like that
absolutely because but i'm sure role
players are in there
and uh we always tell young players or
whoever
is playing in those two minutes play
your minutes these guys are
professionals
they're getting a paycheck every first
and 15. this is not college where
you try to be politically correct no
this guy
that you're facing he is getting a
paycheck
play your minutes now some of the
unwritten rules
if you're up double digits and the shot
clock is running down and the game is
almost over
then you don't want to take a three then
you don't go the hole
because then i'm gonna probably try to
take you out the air the game is over
okay so that's an unwritten rule and
that was kind of the issue kobe and i
had
when that fight happened between us
which will be a different story
i'm not going anywhere you go look at
the footage
that's what kind of led to that little
altercation between kobe and i
wait wait wait explain that though can
you give me a little bit of the
backstory on
look you're going to win the game you're
up double digits
so let's say there's uh you know 30
seconds left on
in the game and it's a 24 second shot
clock
what you're supposed to do is take the
violation let the shot clock run down so
there's only six seconds left
i take the ball out six seconds we go
home you don't try to jack up a three
to get your stats or whatever i'm
looking at it right now
and he and i were having words about
that
and then that's what led to the fight
but
that was toby being kobe and you know
i we just had a little disagreement he
shot it right
in your face he shot her he didn't make
it but he shot it right in my face
and then i got in his face and he got in
my face
and then and you guys were buddies
weren't you weren't you off season
workout buddies
we were early on in our career oh then
you used to
yeah this happened yes this is yes early
on we did
mtv shoots together same agency
yeah i gotta raise them i put them under
my my you know a little i gave him
nooks yeah he was all that for me give
me your little fella
i got shaq moving the entire pile
in this shaq was picking up guys like
with his fingertips
like this i was like yeah that was um
that was it see i missed that i just oh
no you don't
no you don't know you look porzingis
gets thrown out
for looking at marcus morris crazy are
you kidding me
oh i know i know come on man you know
i got i got austin crozier
got he's always got he got a bad austin
got a bad
i gotta die it was a good fight
it staples the gate look this is the
game was over
and we went at it that's what was
beautiful about it oh i miss it
ron artest is trying to break it up
you can see no one going around wrong oh
man
and then just shock is just separating
people
where are you in there are you
we're at the bottom oh it's great
i got isaiah in there jermaine o'neal
phil
jackson's in there yes yes it was good
you got hall of famers in there man and
this is right at the end
and oh there you go we're supposed to be
walking to our respective
locker rooms and tunnels and then he
said something to me
i said something to me we turned around
we locked eyes
and it was on look at austin austin
crosier's
jersey is ripped kobe's being escorted
he wants a piece of somebody there
oh no he's coming back for more he wants
so do you ever discuss that after
after the fact did you and kobe ever
talk about that we didn't necessarily
talk about the fight per se
we kind of kissed and made up um
i think maybe my last year which was
0.506 we kind of you know
hey dog i'm i'm sorry i'm like okay you
know
i'm sorry it was it was kind of blown
out
it was a little bit fake fake bro
fake bro yeah like i love kobe because
that dude's a competitor
and i like having fights with guys that
are similar to me
maybe that's why i got it so many times
with jordan i put kobe in that same
breath
um because i look at them and i see
myself in the mirror
but i still go back to the story where
you said if you saw jordan in a
restaurant
you wouldn't know if you would either
say something to him or punch him
or not say anything right right uh no i
would probably be cordial and say
something i mean you have to
you just say hi hey how are you doing
your airness
and keep it moving yeah yeah nice to see
you black jesus
enjoy your meal hey uh have fun uh hope
the family's safe
and then uh we'll talk to you next week
thank you theodore love you dana
that's reggie aloysius miller junior iii